main street
hey partner hi hey i'm officer park with
acquire police department
uh
only reason why i'm pulling you over uh
i guess y'all were well that's my chief
of police right there he saw you all go
around traffic he was trying to figure
out
who who you are with or what was going
on okay so he called out on the radio
and asked for martin and that's why i
got you pulled over that's fine so um
out now just let him come up if you want
you want to ask who you all work for
georgia metropolitan
you see all the lights on why is the car
registered to an individual that's mine
so what are you doing with all these red
lights sorry why all this emergency
lights
and did i see you using emergency lights
to pull out into traffic on lakewood
that's a stand still so i thought you
liked hoping to see me that i was trying
to get in the line who do you work for
this is my company i'm an off-roading
hero operator this is my company okay
yeah i do for no details
yeah you look like me you're
impersonating a police officer oh no sir
i'm not in first place so
we got any id on you yes sir we look in
the front are you looking at them i see
red lights i saw red lights when you
pulled out yeah that's right that's when
it activated to the back yeah where's
your id right yesterday
do you have a do you have a lighting
permit for the vehicle yeah right down
the glass
okay
thank you sir good luck be right back
with you okay all right
yeah it's got a light permit
i'm just looking at this sir
the light permits uh good through
december of this year
hey chief what do you say that cross was
where you saw him activate the lights on
lake hackworth
what's the name of the 70s
awkward
muffler out on the 92 in that spring of
traffic there anytime okay
okay so near cherokee street
that is roughly
about about 300 feet
he's got a windshield tent
are
that's valid
if you have a lighting permit that's
valid for the vehicle
right
that's what he fears about if he has a
company that does escorts
i'd have to look back in the law i don't
i would assume it's amber amber or white
right um but at the very least from what
keeps saying he's improperly using them
he's not on an escort he's just trying
to keep his traffic so at the very least
i didn't want any proper use of
uh
west
ocga
all right mr becky there's your id back
thank you look um
given with all the light and permanent
stuff i'm seeing i'm just gonna assume
everything's properly permitted and
stuff for the vehicle it is sir that
said with what my chiefs observation you
know the use of those are for strictly
business purposes you can't you can't be
using it to pull in the traffic okay yes
sir so i am gonna issue a citation for
unlawful operation for emergency vehicle
okay
just just here we just talked to the
chief real quick before because i'm
telling you how it's going to work even
though i doing this on my private side
once i get this ticket g-dot it's going
to ground me again i'm going to get
grounded and i trying to that's why i
try to don't interfere my personal
business with gdot anytime they run a
driver's license number i'm going to get
grounded i'm pleased i asked the chief
please i hear but you have to understand
that this whole this whole scenario is a
big issue for us too because the uniform
and lights and all that this is one of
those the thing is this is my company i
run my company respectfully okay because
i deal with high clients this is my
uniform not normally say officer nothing
this is my uniform i got you you
understand but please i just want to
talk to chief i know you're going to
still do your job i mean no harm you can
check me my bachelor's fault for
everyone express means just hear me out
i don't want to get it if if the chief
wants target that's fine but this is
going to stand all right just let me
explain this what i need to do is sign
here at the x signing is not going to
know
[Music]
everything i point out to everyone else
auto generated court date right now is
showing for the 18th of august at 9 00
a.m at our court the address is right
there on the backyard copy this phone
number right here is to the court
services takes about three to five
business days for the citation give them
a call and i'll explain everything to
you okay do you have any further i have
to attend the court i just compared
because
i already once you contact that number
they'll tell you all your options if uh
if you can just pay it out right and
they'll explain your payment problem
have you got a business card
can i step out
and you're all hot but what about all
these people in there i know ain't no
that's not the one that's for them yeah
they're trying to crack the winner right
now chief don't you open all the windows
no the thing is when i ride when i ride
the air the
compressor is going to kick in
yeah
chief yeah i'm not trying to be an
opinion in your hip the chief please man
i don't want to get grounded please from
g-dot please
i get that i live in i live in the
community i live right there on uh 30-45
i'm not a bad person please chief i beg
of you i don't think you're bad let me
have your business card i don't think
you're a bad person no i just don't want
to get impersonating a police officer i
do not i don't want to know i don't
impersonate police officers sir that's
why i was careful i i present myself on
my uniform also i'm a former police in
the bahamas
i don't have nothing that impersonate
paul
we need real cops i know you could apply
i don't want to honestly i don't want to
apply for awkward
i yeah i don't want to apply for awkward
if it's hard to find your business card
just what's good funding before you sir
okay anytime all right thank you very
much sir all right unless you have any
other questions you're free to leave
see
i want to verify your employment and i'm
probably going to have cid looking for
this to be honest
i
and also an author right here yeah
that's why he was calling my supervisor
just now
all right that's that's that's between
you and your boss okay yeah like i said
we'll do our follow-up book
[Music]
oh god
[Applause]
you